Instructor: A couple
of videos back, we talked about
a WeakSet where it gets garbage
collected. A WeakMap is pretty
much exactly the same thing.
A WeakMap doesn't have a size.
You can never tell how many
elements are in it. A WeakMap is
not enumerable, which means you
cannot loop over it. The items
inside of a WeakMap, if they no
longer exist anywhere else in
your application, they will get
garbage collected and they'll be
removed from your WeakMap.
Let's go through a quick example
of where we have a regular map
and a regular WeakMap, and we'll
show exactly the difference here.
We'll create two objects here,
then
we'll create two maps. We'll add
a button to each of the maps.
Notice how I'm using the keys
here, which are objects.
Let's take a look at what we've
got here. We've got strong,
which is our actual map here.
Oops, we got to say weak.set.
Strong should have one item in
it, good, and weak should have
another item in it. Good.
They each have one item in it.
If I were to say weak.size, we
get nothing. But if I say strong.
size, we get 1. Why? Because a
WeakMap doesn't have a size.
Even though DevTools knows what
it is here, you cannot get the
size of a WeakMap at all. Now,
let's go and delete some of them.
dog1 = null, dog2 = null. We've
created these, we've added them
to the map, and then we've
deleted them. Let's take a look
at our maps here. What is the
error here? Assignment to
constant variable. Cannot do
this, so we would have to say
let dog, not const dog. We
have our strong, still has an
item in it. Weak, it might still
have an item in it. It takes a
while to get garbage collected.
Oh, nothing there. We no
longer have a dog1, and we no
longer have a dog2, but the
strong one is still holding onto
this object that no longer
exists. That's a memory leak
there, because there's no way
for us to reference it, whereas
the WeakMap has totally cleaned
it up. Garbage collection has
happened and we no longer
reference it there. If you
need something like that, where
it gets garbage collected, where
you don't have to babysit what
is and isn't inside of the map,
then that's the case where you
reach for a WeakMap over a map.